now that he's won his defamation trial
can johnny depp's career bounce back the
producer of pirates of the caribbean has
a few things to say about that
he's heavy
the blockbuster court battle of 2022 has
reached its conclusion as the verdict of
the johnny depp amber heard lawsuits
ended with the jury ruling for death on
three counts of defamation to the tune
of 15 million dollars in compensatory
and punitive damages one competing claim
of defamation went for her with two
million dollars of compensatory damages
awarded but she still owes much more
money to debt than she gained and with
her having been found to have defamed
her ex-husband with actual malice in a
2018 op-ed depp has emerged as the clear
winner of the trial but was it enough to
restore his damaged reputation some
might be wondering what happens to depp
now including the actor himself
during his cross-examination depp spoke
about the effect of hurt's 2018
allegations saying once that happened i
lost then no matter the outcome of this
trial i'll carry that for the rest of my
days i'm suing her over defamation and
the various falsities that she used to
bring my life to an end i would live
with that
for the rest of my life
because of the allegations depp might
feel that his career is done but history
indicates it might be safe to expect
otherwise after all hollywood loves a
dramatic comeback story and while his
reputation may have suffered there's
reason to believe that he's gearing up
for a grand return whether he realizes
it or not
according to crisis management expert
eric rose both depp and heard emerged
from the court battle looking
significantly worse for wear
reputation-wise he told the associated
press from a reputation management
perspective there can be no winners they
bloodied each other up it becomes more
difficult now for studios to hire either
actor because you're potentially
alienating a large segment of your
audience who may not like the fact that
you have retained either johnny or amber
for a specific project because feelings
are so strong now
dev's career was also on the wane even
before the trial and he'd built a
reputation as an unprofessional worker
in recent years not to mention the
frequent reports of substance abuse but
as anyone who's paid attention to the
trial has no doubt discovered his fans
are very very vocal they also want to
see him in many films to come not only
did we have a group of dev fans that
were there every day a hundred were
allowed in they lined up at one o'clock
in the morning for their wristbands in
fact according to a survey by spotted
media over 86 percent of respondents
think that depp should continue his film
career while almost two-thirds would
happily see herds come to an end the ceo
of the publication explained i think the
results show pretty clearly that johnny
depp is extremely hirable and that it
would be a risk to a production company
to hire amber heard because of the
precipitous drop in appeal that she has
had since the beginning of the trial
according to the times even depp's
return to the pirates of the caribbean
franchise isn't entirely ruled out
assuming that the actor himself would be
willing to return when producer jerry
brockheimer was asked about depp's
potential return as jack sparrow in may
brackheimer simply said not at this
point the future is yet to be decided if
you look at other disgraced actors who
came before him it's not hard to imagine
him becoming hollywood's next big
comeback kid robert downey jr spent a
long time as a virtually unhirable
outcast with high profile arrests and
substance abuse issues before his
gradual career re-emergence and rise to
the marvel cinematic universe
mountaintop mickey roarick also had it
rough before the wrestler briefly made
him a household name again mel gibson's
various well-documented offensive
remarks and allegations of abuse didn't
stop his 2016 war movie hacksaw ridge
from getting six academy award
nominations including best director
dep's reputation might be in shambles
right now and the people who continue to
support herd are unlikely to approve any
project he's a part of anytime soon
however in the long run and as far as
the industry is concerned the court
still ruled in depth's favor and in the
court of public opinion he looks like
the clear winner
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the latest hot topics are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]